hey guys i'm abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen today's edition of what I
eat in a day youtuber review is
sponsored by Skillshare and we're gonna
be taking a look at youtuber Meggie
McDonald now before we get too far into
things I want to chat about what I've
been learning through my Skillshare
membership while social distancing at
home if you haven't heard of Skillshare
they're an online learning community
with a wide range of amazing creative
classes for exploring new skills
developing interests and getting lost in
your own creativity I think a lot of us
are dealing with a lot of extra stress
and anxiety over the future right now
and I also know a lot of people might be
thinking about ways to learn some new
skills and diversify in their careers so
I've been taking a course called
everyday minimalism finding calm and
creativity in living simply by Erin
Boyle now these lessons have been so
great for stress relief and have also
encouraged me to learn some new habits
that I can incorporate into my life even
after this whole covin 19 thing passes
there are also a ton of amazing drawing
writing and journaling classes I'm
definitely gonna be checking out next
all of which I think will be amazing for
my anxiety before baby comes so whether
you're bored need some extra self-care
or want to join a creative community
while in isolation Skillshare is a great
resource during these times and beyond
and for my viewers and fans Skillshare
is giving away two free months of their
premium membership to the first 1000
people who click the link in the
description box to help you explore your
creativity and after that it's just ten
dollars a month okay so let's get into
this video here maggie is a plant-based
influencer who shares her life through
blogs on youtube with her sister Emma
and according to her what I attend a
videos is currently following her
version of a food combining diet
now not surprisingly she is also BFFs
with someone who I've reviewed on this
channel before Kenzie Burke now in case
you missed my review of the food
combining diet with Kenzie Burke
definitely be sure to check it out right
here I also did a blog post on the food
combining diet so if you want some more
information I'm going to be leaving a
link to that in the description below
and finally before we jump into our
review I want to serve with my general
disclaimer but the information in this
video is for entertainment and
educational purposes only and you should
always seek out the help of a registered
dietitian or a medical professional for
your unique case so let's meet Maggie
and take a look at her first meal of the
day not that it really like matters but
it's nine o'clock I just obviously
showered my hair is what my sister Emma
and I went to a yoga scops class this
morning at 7:30 so it was kind of like a
rushed morning just because my alarm
didn't go off
and I ended up like waking up at 7:05
and then I had to leave and get ready
and tough so I had a cup of hot lemon
water before class but I didn't eat
anything in the morning just because I
knew that I was going to come home and
like have breakfast and do all that so I
didn't eat anything this is the first
thing that I will be eating today banana
and ginger and then I added in some cow
powder and two spices I use cardamon
which is gonna give you like the chai
taste and then also added some cinnamon
and we put spinach in this time um I
don't know how the color is gonna turn
out if it's gonna be super pretty but we
just wanted to add in a little bit more
greens and then put coconut milk in for
the base we just added some shredded
coconut onto the top and then also some
cacao nibs which is like I put cacao in
this movie okay so I get that some
people don't like a big breakfast before
a workout and that's totally cool and
depending on when you're working out and
the type of working out that you're
doing there may actually be some small
benefits for some people to doing it
fasted but Maggie's justifications seems
to be that she was like in a rush and
didn't have time to eat not so much for
any of the alleged health benefits of
fasting
and honestly I would say if you have
time for hot lemon water and to film
your day you probably have time to grab
like a banana or orange on the go but
again whatever if you're not a breakfast
person not to sweat you do you it
actually is totally fine
now before we get into her smoothie I
did want to do a quick little refresher
on food combining so the food combining
diet is a set of rules that insist that
you eat some foods together and others
separately in order to improve and
enhance digestion so for example some
common food combining rules include only
eating fruit on an empty stomach not
combining starches with protein not
combining different types of protein not
combining starches with acidic foods not
mixing protein with fat and eating
fruits and vegetables separately sounds
crazy restrictive No now even though
Meggy smoothie does sound like super
delicious because banana and chocolate
is everything in life and I love
everything to do with chai there's no
protein in sight her smoothie is mainly
made up of carbs from the banana and
maybe like a little bit from the coconut
milk and sprinkle of cacao nibs I mean
if you're watching this like me
wondering why you wouldn't want to get
at least a little more protein in after
a workout
or even at breakfast when you're not
working out let me explain this in food
combining speak now basically the theory
behind food combining is that when we
combine starches and protein we're
apparently putting too much strain on
our digestive system one analogy that we
can use to explain this theory is peanut
butter toast now food combining
supporters believe that when you eat
fast digesting foods like bread and slow
digesting foods like peanut butter
you'll cause a traffic jam in your
digestive tract this peanut butter toast
traffic jam will supposedly negatively
affect your digestion resulting in
disease toxic buildup bloating I
yes and other forms of digestive stress
to prevent that food combiners eat the
peanut butter and the toast separately I
know how sad is that now before we talk
more about food combining I want to get
back to Maggie's post-workout smoothie
here now even though I am a big fan of
that ingredient combo banana and
chocolate and I would totally be down to
have that as a snack as her first meal
of the day and a post-workout meal at
that definitely leaves much to be
desired now we know how important
protein is for post-workout muscle
recovery so I would really have liked to
see Maggie have some protein with her
carbs for that first meal I also really
hope Maggie is not relying on that small
serving of cacao nibs as her source of
protein as three tablespoons of cacao
nibs provide only four grams of protein
and if I had to guess it looks like
she's maybe getting less than a
tablespoon in there that is really not
sufficient whatsoever as you typically
want to aim for about 20 to 30 grams of
protein post-exercise not only to help
with muscle recovery but also to keep
you satiated longer to get you to that
next meal let's take a look at day two
we start off the morning every single
day I just have my big liter of water
right here and I made some hot lemon
water and I just take my probiotic this
is the brand that I use it's called seed
so I take two of these and then also my
daily vitamin already just made what I'm
having for breakfast to start the day
you guys would have seen that and every
morning I like to start off with like a
bowl a big bowl of fruit with some type
of plant-based yogurt and this is my
favorite thing in the world I look
forward to it every day I have a few
plain face you look inside I just wanted
to tell you guys about and this is my
favorite one it is by the brand lava and
I love it because the ingredients are
super simple it's very clean and there's
just minimal things in it
okay so we are kicking things off here
with her supplements I'm not really sure
what kind of vitamins are in that little
package there but I'm glad that she at
least is mentioning she's taking
supplements so that's a good start
as for her breakfast well I mean it's a
little more substantial than her banana
spinach smoothie thing on day one but
still kind of pleased by the bogus food
combining rules of eating fruits on an
empty stomach
that said the yogurt has just 2 grams of
protein per container which is really
not a lot it's got some fat which is
good but still doesn't make for a very
satiating breakfast in my books also of
course I'm not loving her labeling the
yogurt as clean I get what she's saying
that it's got a simple ingredient list
but I just think this talk feeds into
diet culture and we don't need more of
that folks the only clean eating that we
should all be doing is washing our
fruits and vegetables am i right yeah
I'm definitely right okay let's get
today free and now we are done I love
putting everything on top because I feel
like when you drink it it helps so you
don't hate drink it superfast because
I'm the type of person where this would
be gone in like two minutes
so I'd love to just add a little
toppings you can do like goji berries
whatever you really want I just love
doing cacao nibs and coconut yeah so
it's been a little bit and I'm actually
gonna make like my actual breakfast now
I love having a smoothie in the morning
and like getting in all those nutrients
and I love eating fruit but it
definitely doesn't like hold me over I
get super hungry
after I have fruit or like a smoothie or
anything it just doesn't do it for me
okay so same thing but different this
smoothie seems to have bananas mangoes
it's got some spinach some ginger and
some cucumber and then it's blended
together with coconut water so I'm not
exactly shocked that Meggy isn't fully
satisfied after her fruit smoothie in
the morning I mean this is actually
quite common even with the mo
most balanced of breakfast smoothies in
my opinion it would obviously take us
way longer to chew a banana and then
chew one cup of spinach and eat a
handful of cacao nibs
but blending all these ingredients
together into one compact drink
basically makes it so there's less work
that your body needs to do to digest
that smoothie so your smoothie kind of
enters your stomach predigested thereby
skipping a step in digestion and fast
tracking the absorption into the body
and because Meggy smoothie left any sort
of protein to help kind of hold her a
little bit longer she most likely got
that little burst of energy from a quick
spike in blood sugar and then was left
feeling pretty hungry
soon after okay so let's move along to
her second breakfast or her first snack
depending on how you want to look at
things i swear that the lemon on top of
the avocado toast is such a game-changer
like i don't know why i haven't been
doing this forever it just makes it so
good I started to squeeze all the juice
of half of the lemon on top this is my
favorite part of every single day the
avocado toast with the matcha is just
like the best thing in the whole world I
really love it so much and I've already
started eating it and I'm just gonna
drink the matcha and have some work to
do on my computer okay so I am already
sensing and no protein pattern from
Maggie as it's already in the afternoon
and there is still no protein to be had
so her avocado toast is made up of
really only fat from the avocado carbs
from the bread a little squeeze of lemon
juice and quite a lot of chili flakes I
would probably be sweating now I know I
may ruffle a few feathers here
especially among those in the alkaline
food sphere but lemon in its predigested
state is acidic in PH so if the food
combining rule is to not add acidic
foods to starches is based on their
predigested state
it definitely technically breaks the
rules like it matters
then again who knows maybe maggie is
banking on the rule taking into account
that lemon juice produces alkaline
byproducts when it's digested who knows
I mean honestly it doesn't matter either
way because the whole thing is bunk now
Serena's have consistently shown that
even though lemon juice produces
alkaline byproducts in the urine it
actually does not have any effects on
blood pH and while we're at it I think
it's important to note that no foods
have an alkalizing effect on blood pH so
from that perspective we can't really
call lemon and alkaline food but anyways
I digress let's take a look at day two
we are a little pre lunch moment that
was so aggressive but Mediterranean
toast
I just drizzled the balsamic on top it
is so good stacked everything up oh this
is my favorite okay so first of all YUM
and second of all finally we see an
appropriate meal whether she wants to
call it a snack or breakfast or lunch
whatever we have here a bit of protein
from the hummus some cars from the
sourdough bread fat from the olives and
some extra veggies on top thank you food
combining gods for allowing this meal
I mean if it's even allowed to be honest
because there is some protein with some
starch so who knows stupid rules aside I
do in a point out that Maggie says her
bread of choice is sourdough when she's
not having gluten free bread but that
makes me also wonder why she's choosing
gluten-free bread at all
I mean if Maggie was eating gluten-free
bread because of a gluten intolerance or
celiac disease it would make complete
sense why she would want to eat
gluten-free bread but if she's able to
eat sourdough no problem that tells me
that these maybe aren't really huge
issues I will say however that the
fermentation process of sourdough bread
does make it easier to digest not only
because of the prebiotic and probiotic
like properties which are beneficial for
overall gut
and digestion but also because the
process also degrades gluten a little
bit making the gluten content lower than
other breads however it doesn't degrade
glynn completely so sourdough bread
still contains wheat barley or rye and
should be avoided by people with actual
gluten intolerance or celiac disease
just an FYI if some of you were also a
little confused about that based on
these kinds of comments and what we've
seen so far from Maggie's videos I get a
little bit of an impression that she's
fallen for a lot of the diet culture
rhetoric from clean eating to super
foods gluten-free even the morning
requisite lemon water we are seeing a
lot of unnecessary food rules and
rituals playing out let's take a look at
day three once it's all done I usually
just add some sort of hot sauce on top
because I'm obsessed with hot sauce so I
have the sriracha that I've been loving
recently and it's jalapeno and then we
also have this one right here which is
just the C at a traditional hot sauce
seriously girl that is a lot of hot
sauce I mean I am a big sriracha person
myself but the amount of hot sauce when
you're seeing Negi put on her avocado
toast is already giving me the sweats
maybe it's the pregnancy I'm not sure
but I also want to comment that adding a
lot of hot sauce or hot things to meals
has long being a weight loss tactic as
research has shown that consuming hot
sauce or or a lot of heat and spice in
large amounts has been shown to help
reduce appetite now considering just how
low-calorie maggie's meals have been
thus far I'm really just hoping that
she's not using the excessive heat to
suppress her appetite I mean if she
loves a good kick
girl amen to that but just something
that I wanted to flag in the context of
everything I've
thus far but let's move on to lunch
lunch is done this is the finished
product just topped it off with some
more red pepper flakes and pepper was a
good and I feel like chickpea pasta has
I don't know I feel like it's kind of
like dry so I added a little bit more
lemon and then I just put some
nutritional yeast on the top so it'll
just like out a little bit of something
to it all right
hallelujah folks we finally have some
protein happening here with the chickpea
pasta so with this meal
Maggie's getting probably around 20
grams of protein which is a totally
appropriate amount of protein for a meal
so I'm really happy to see that I am
personally obsessed with chickpea pasta
as it is an easy way to get your protein
in without having to worry about cooking
up some meat or plant-based protein if
you're not totally feeling it especially
a good call for picky toddlers who
basically just want to eat carbs all day
I love that stuff now with this meal
make he's getting roughly 17 grams of
protein which I'm really happy to see
because that is a perfectly appropriate
amount for a meal we also are getting
some healthy fats from the avocado and
olive oil and lots of beautiful
vegetables going on but back to my food
combining beef one of the biggest issues
with food combining is the inability to
actually separate macronutrients from
each other in a lot of foods case in
point
chickpea pasta so like I mentioned one
of the food combining rules is to not
eat starches and protein together so we
know that chickpea pasta provides about
17 grams of protein but it also has 51
grams of carbohydrate which totally goes
against this whole food combining rule
and also speaks to just how
unsustainable and unrealistic this diet
really is I mean we even see Meggy add
some acidity to her meal with apple
cider vinegar which also goes against
one of the food combining rules bottom
line these rules are stupid and
obviously
are unlikely to be followed properly so
why would you even bother stressing over
them I don't know let's take a look at
day two all right
so things are starting to look much
better around here Meggie went for lunch
with her family and chose a miso bowl
with jasmine rice edamame chickpeas
falafel and a variety of veggies plus
she had Brussels sprouts and shishitos
both of which looked insanely good I
don't know about you but I'm kind of
thinking Meggie should maybe eat out
with her mom more often but anyways this
meal
obviously breaks a ton of the food
combining rules for instance it combines
different types of protein like edamame
and chickpeas and falafel it also
combines starch with the jasmine rice
with protein which as we already
established is apparently a big bogus no
no not to mention this meal also mixes
protein and fat from the dressing which
goes against more food combining rules
and guess what I have not mad about this
what so ever
this is Ashley what I'm hoping to see
from Maggie in her videos and I'm I'm
really glad that she finally delivered
something balanced that I can totally
get on board with please Maggie let's
see more restaurant meals maybe and less
smoothies let's take a look at day three
so I'm going to be making like a little
wrap for lunch
with them honestly I'm gonna make two
laps I'm look extremely hungry because
it might work out
I ended up putting half of an avocado in
here so we have little wraps hummus
sprouts veggies hot sauce all of that
and then just some cut-up cucumber on
the side okay so this meal while it
totally looks really tasty is pretty low
carb low protein low calorie you get it
I mean Maggie opts for a low carb
coconut wrap which sounds like crackling
paper or something when she tries to
wrap it up but I hope it tastes okay and
again we're seeing a ton of veggies not
a whole lot of substance she is getting
a small amount of protein from the
hummus but again not nearly the
appropriate amount that you probably
want to see for a meal honestly I'm
seeing a lot of green going on here and
that's about it
which is perhaps the only consistent
thing about Maggie's eating pattern thus
far and to be fair she did bless us with
some definite balance with her previous
two lunches but this one is a bit of a
flop so I think we're looking at two out
of three when it comes to Maggie's
lunches which I guess it's not so bad
let's take a look at her afternoon that
snack mat I didn't think we really need
to see more greens after everything
we've seen thus far but I don't know if
she was feeling it I mean I'm a
dietitian I am generally happy to see
people eat more green things so I'm not
going to complain about that let's take
a look at day two
okay maybe I'm gonna complain about it
I'm just kidding I same same but
different right more green juice this
time she made it at home which is of
course way more cost-effective but
probably unnecessary given how many
greens and vegetables we see in her day
let's take a look at day three but I'm
probably gonna have like a little bit of
the plantain chips or salsa and then
some cauliflower tortilla chips with the
cashew queso cuz I'm so hungry and
another thing I wanted to show while
we're having this intact I'm over here
is the ingredients on all these snacks
see these are super clean the plantain
chips just plantains coconut oil and
pink Himalayan salt and then the queso
has all of these ingredients you can
pause it and read it right now but
everything is clean again you can just
like easily pronounce everything which
is what you want and then this is the
salsa super clean we're obsessed with
this salsa right here and then to finish
off we have the cauliflower tortilla
chips and these are the ingredients for
the chip so again they're all just super
clean oh my gosh so much clean you would
think we are in like a mr. clean
commercial or selling with the amount of
times we're hearing the word clean
thrown around but what I will say is
checking ingredient lists and nutrition
labels is totally actually a great way
to compare different food products but
being overly concerned with what is
deemed clean and what isn't can easily
be taken to an unhealthy extreme we eat
for health but we also eat for
satisfaction and I would way rather hear
Meggy comment on what she likes about
these snacks how they taste and what
makes them yummy and satisfying for her
versus what is and isn't on the
ingredient label and
the only deciding factor so with this
snack we are gam seeing the green juice
plus some vegetable crackers and I think
like some salsa or something so a little
more substantial than just the vegetable
juice but I would have liked to see a
little fat in there some protein
something to bulk this up to make it a
more satiating snack let's take a look
at dinner need some salt and some pink
salt and pepper and I'm just gonna add
some of this seasoning from Trader Joe's
I've been really liking it so we're
gonna add some of it on top I don't know
why it's so hard for to come out of the
container but I'm gonna add it mix it up
and let it sit for a little bit longer
and dinner is almost done I think we're
gonna put nutritional yeast on the top
but all the veggies are cooked and then
we just put some pesto on top and that
my friends is the reason that we do not
need to buy or make green juice every
day
Meggy is literally eating a bowl of
steamed vegetables for dinner just
vegetables okay I mean yes there are
some ham parts based pesto and some
nutritional yeast on top both of which
will contribute some protein but like
still this is a very low calorie
relatively low protein low carb and low
fat meal she does mention that her and
her sister usually make this meal with
some coconut rice but they weren't in
the mood tonight which is totally ok I
mean listen to your body listen to what
you're craving but why not just
substitute that for another curb instead
of just eliminating it entirely quinoa
soba noodles couscous bread potatoes I
can think of a lot of ways to beef this
up
ditto with the protein I mean you could
easily throw in some chickpeas or some
tofu now you guys know I am all about
eating intuitively and following your
hunger signals but taken in the context
of her whole day it's just not enough
food please Lord let there be some tofu
or quinoa or chickpeas on day 2 let's
take a look
right so dinner is done I added some red
chili flakes on the top and what I like
to do whenever I have pasta is I like to
fill it with vegetables so you guys
obviously saw all the veggies I just
cooked it adds more volume to the pasta
so having that and then big salad right
here which just has some olives I added
red onion and dill and then the lemon
tahini dressing okay so we are back with
another pasta recipe but unfortunately I
don't think this one is chickpea pasta
it doesn't look like it anyways so no
major source of protein it seems like
Maggi picks and chooses when she abides
by the food combining rules depending on
what she's eating or where she is and
that's totally fine I mean I'd rather
she didn't abide by them at all so as we
saw from her lunch she totally stepped
outside of the restrictions of food
combining and had an actual complete
balanced meal that broke nearly every
rule in the food combining book which is
a big yay in my books but now of course
we're back the dinner and we're getting
right back on track with the food
combining trained with the protein
restriction now to her credit I imagine
that it must be really challenging for
people following this diet to meet their
protein needs since a lot of the rules
here in the spoon combining world limit
or restrict protein in some way and that
means the only option is to get your
protein basically by itself eating it
all on its own which is not very
exciting but if she actually insists on
following the rules as bogus
as they are she could include more
protein rich snacks in between her meals
rather than relying on smoothies juices
and avocado toasts just saying I'm also
kind of feeling a little weird about her
saying that she likes to feel her pasta
with lots of veggies specifically to add
more volume to her meals now I am all
about adding more vegetables to my meals
but the innate purpose should be to add
more nutritional value texture and
flavor to your meals not just add more
volume now the volume thing may actually
be
tool for a lot of people based on their
health status and their goals and I
totally support that but for an active
young woman like Maggie who is basically
already subsisting on vegetables this
seems like total overkill let's take a
look at day three I was supposed to go
to a 7:30 SoulCycle with Gretchen today
but her and I are just feeling like so
tired and we knew that we wanted to like
a letter body's rest okay so if you've
been following my channel for a while
you know that I talk a lot about
intuitive eating but it's just as
important to move your body in an
intuitive way as well it can be so easy
to kind of get caught up in our workout
routines and feel obligated to follow
through with them even when our body is
saying no so I can totally get on board
with what maggie is saying here about
listening to your body when it needs its
rest and just tending to its needs let's
take a look at her meal and I'm excited
to see it she's excited to see it so
let's see dinner is ready it took
literally like 30 minutes to make and
this is the finished product so we have
spinach chickpeas right here black
olives tomato mushrooms peppers and then
underneath there is all white rice and
then Emma just added some Liquid aminos
some coconut liquid aminos to hers
obviously you guys already know I have
my favorite hot sauce that I'm gonna put
my mind to so this is dinner
super easy quick yummy amazing so
finally we've got some more balance here
what I have just been craving so we have
of course two lots of vegetables which
is a great thing but this time we've got
some chick peas and some jasmine rice on
the bottom now I can't actually see the
rice but I'm assuming it's there and in
that case I give this meal a gold star
for breaking the stupid food combining
rule so well done Maggie I'm so proud
okay now let's close off on dessert
because
I am still hungry this baby needs to be
fed let's take a look at day one it's
very unexpected with us but I got a size
two chocolate with cacao Jizzle pink
salt coconut and chocolate chips so it
looks amazing and this stuff is so good
yes Maggie I love this as dessert and
what I love even more is how Maggie's
talking about her ice cream selection
she didn't choose it because it was
clean or healthy at least she didn't say
that but she chose it because she
genuinely enjoys the flavor combination
of chocolate and coconut and I mean who
doesn't especially with that pink
Himalayan salt on top yes love that
let's take a look at day two at night
this is an OG on my channel this whoo
chocolate I really like the mint one I
just had a few squares of this Tyler
actually got me this for Valentine's Day
because he knows I love it so much but
this really helps me if I have a sweet
tooth and I need something after I eat
and also obviously ingredients super
clean and I really like this they have a
bunch of different flavors too they have
like men's they have sea salts they have
a really good haze a lot one so there's
a bunch of different ones to try I just
made my pre-bedtime T this is the toasty
cleanse I really like this one and I
just have this before I go to bed helps
me wind down and it's just very
cleansing for your body so I like to
have this at the end of the day it's car
ah Maggie why you gotta ruin my mood
like that I was riding so high on that
first ice cream dessert but I knew
sooner or later I would probably hear my
favorite word cleanse now before we get
into another cleanse rant I do want to
point out that maggie has not had one
but two teas in the evening this is
likely perfectly normal behavior for
most people in fact I think tea is a
great way to get in your fluid needs
without added sugar and it's a really
great soothing pairing for that
chocolate which looks delicious by the
way but given what I've seen from
Maggie's channel so far and the fact
that she specifically chosen a cleansing
tea I hope that she isn't using the tea
to add volume to her stomach the same
way she talks about using vegetables at
dinner I did actually take a peek at the
ingredient list for this tea and the
main ingredient I saw was ginger now
I've seen a lot of influencers turn to
ginger tea to help with bloating and in
digestion and research ashley has shown
that ginger tea may be effective at
helping with bloating from indigestion
and also may help to reduce nausea
there's nothing magical about ginger tea
or any other tea for that matter that
cleanses or detoxifies besides just
being a natural diuretic and making you
pee more and something that I must say
that I've said before and I will say
again for as long as I have to the only
scientifically proven way to actually
cleanse or detoxify your body is to
simply rely on your trusty organs your
kidneys liver lungs skin and digestive
tract do all the work for you I say just
save all that money and spend it on tea
that you actually enjoy or like more
chocolate whatever works for you let's
take a look at day three and after
dinner I love to have any type of ginger
tea my favorite is the Tulsi lemon and
ginger and it just really soothes my
stomach and satisfies me and it's just
such a nice like warm
treat to have after I eat we help just
like a bunch of chocolate but I have so
much chocolate this one's my favor and I
love the salty dark chocolate one and
then also
the mint one forgot to vlog but I made
some of the magnesium calm like drink
the lemon flavor that I was talking
about earlier so I but I will update you
guys in the morning how this worked just
because I want to be able to tell you
guys so I'm gonna head to bed but I'm
not gonna end off the video because I
have a few things that I'm gonna go over
in the morning just like how this worked
and other things that I want to talk
about okay so again we saw the same tea
and the same kind of chocolate and as
for the magnesium supplement it is true
that there is research to support the
use of magnesium for regulating sleep
since it helps calm the body by
targeting the parasympathetic nervous
system while also regulating the sleep
hormone melatonin it also binds to the
neurotransmitter gaba which is
responsible for calming nerve activity
so I'm glad that Maggie is using it for
this purpose but I just want to kind of
give everyone a heads up that the
combination of her magnesium calm
supplement and her cleansing teeth
sounds like it might result in a long
night on the flu you've been warned
magnesium can definitely cause diarrhea
when consumed in excess now before we
get into the final analysis I want to
share this comment from Maggie about her
diet and about food combining in general
honestly like the only thing that I
really focus on is having fruit in the
morning like I don't really eat it in
the afternoon or anything or at
nighttime so that's basically it but the
way that I eat you don't really have to
like put any thought with like combining
your foods because I don't eat any
animal protein so okay so finally the
answer we've all been looking for we've
got a full disclosure of what food
combining really means to Maggie now in
this video which was posted back in
November of last year
Maggie comments on her plant-based food
combining diet and mentions that she
pretty much only really follows the
fruit in the morning rule now I love
fruit in the morning just as much as the
next person but I still have some
serious questions here now technically
with food combined
this rule suggests that you would have
to have fruit by itself on an empty
stomach however we do see Maggie still
combine her fruit with other foods like
yogurt and veggies in her smoothie which
makes me wonder if she's breaking the
stupid food combining rules anyway I
mean why not go all the way and add more
value to your breakfast
or to any of her meals for that reason
now we know that having fruit in the
morning does not hold her over for very
long anyway she said that herself so
this would actually be a pretty easy and
intuitive fix something as simple as
just adding some nut butter or protein
powder to a smoothie or having a handful
of mixed nuts or even swapping out her
coconut yogurt for a soy brand which
would have some more protein I know I've
said the word protein what feels like a
thousand times already in this video but
even though eating plant-based or vegan
in Maggie's case may limit your protein
options there are still plenty of
plant-based protein options available
that Maggie simply is not really
utilizing enough of in her meals I would
just love to see Maggie like readjust
her focus on what's clean or what super
foods she's adding to her meals and
focus more on how to make her meals more
balanced more satiating and ultimately
more nutrient-dense and that may help
prevent any possible nutrition
deficiencies into the future so in
general is this way of eating balanced
I'm gonna say not so much I mean she's
having lots of veggies fruit some
carbohydrates and some fats I'm not
seeing enough consistent protein in her
days depending on the day and this is
part of my issue with food combining
because it just makes it so difficult to
consistently consume enough protein
throughout your meals and snacks because
of so many different rules and
restrictions around not combining
protein with any other food now assuming
an approximate weight of let's say 120
pounds maybe probably should be aiming
for between 55
five and 94 grams approaching depending
on her fitness activity and goals and
after doing a quick nutrient analysis of
her meals it appears that her daily
protein is all over the map
she only hits the minimum protein
requirement for day one and the other
two days she unfortunately falls below
her protein needs which to me is highly
concerning for somebody who is active
and working out now I'm all for eating
in a way that makes you feel good and is
sustainable in the long run and Maggie
seems to be really happy with this way
of eating she talks about it in this
video she says that she's feeling good
and she loves love's loves her diet but
I have to flag that for most people a
diet like this would not be sustainable
and would not feel good so I'm not
surprised that she feels the need to
bulk up a lot of her meals with extra
vegetables in order to feel satisfied
now are there any problematic claims or
assumptions made by this channel I think
I heard Maggie say pretty much every
trendy word in the diet culture handbook
just saying I mean whether we're talking
about clean eating cleansing teas
superfoods lemon water the obsession
with maintaining a clean or pure way of
eating without any sort of wiggle room
really perpetuates a lot of orthotic
ideals and rules that we've seen enough
of here on YouTube I don't think that
Maggie is necessarily purposefully
trying to dupe her followers into kind
of going along with this food combining
lifestyle that she herself is not
qualified to promote I kind of just
think that she has misinformed herself
which is so common in this very
confusing wellness space but I think
when you put yourself out there as a
wellness influencer even if you're not
necessarily selling anything per se you
need to take responsibility for the
information that you're sharing even if
it's painted as just what you do and
what works for you people are bound to
follow now is there anything that we
actually really like from her channel so
as far as the positive things that we've
seen from Maggie's channel this
bite the overall lack of balance I see
her diet I do like the variety that she
has in her meals while still making sure
that she's including foods that she
really loves like avocado toast for
example we do see her share several
different types of meals including
pastas wraps chickpea balls miso bowls
toasts smoothies yogurt bowls all of
which can be excellent meal options when
executed in a balanced way so I'm at
least happy to have that inspiration I
also appreciate her honesty with her
followers when it comes to disclosing
her thoughts on food combining as well
as listening to her body when it comes
to kind of taking a rain check on a
workout when she wasn't feeling up for
it bottom line I can definitely get on
board with the idea of being flexible
and adjusting a diet to make it work for
you the way that Meggie talks about
doing basically with food combining but
what is ultimately the most important
thing to consider is how sustainable the
diet really is and on that note whether
or not they're actually even any likely
benefits which in the case of food
combining
I think we've demonstrated previously
that there are not diets should not make
you feel hungry immediately after eating
a meal like breakfast or make you
restrict important nutrients like
protein or make you feel as though you
can only eat certain foods that are
deemed clean while avoiding other foods
that don't fall into that arbitrary
category these may be problematic
behaviors that have been touted by diet
culture as being normal healthy and
forms of self-care I believe that there
is nothing healthy and caring about
feeling hungry or deprived or restricted
of important nutrition so I do hope that
Maggie continues to move away from the
restrictive food combining rules as
bogus as they are and find ways of
eating that truly serve her and her
health well on that note folks that is
all for today's video thank you again to
Skillshare for sponsoring this video if
you liked it be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below with
who you would like to see me review next
and until then subscribe to the channel
I will see you next time on Abby's
kitchen bye
[Music]